Learning theory,
behaviorism,
there are in conditions,
rewards.
Those are rewards you don't have to learn.
Those are the things that bring a motivated state to its closure,
roughly speaking,
and that makes you satisfied.
Satiation.
That by the way is associated with Serotonin.
Serotonin is a satiating neurochemical,
so if you're hot levels of Serotonin are high,
you're kind of satisfied,
which means you don't experience a lot of positive emotion or a lot of negative
emotion.
You're just kind of satisfied.
It's a high dominance thing.
It's like all the consumer story rewards are there when you need them.
You don't have to worry and you don't have to get too excited.
Conditioned rewards or incentive rewards indicate progress towards a consumer to
consumer Tory reward.
They can be learned or condition,
but they can also be a Nate and their associated with dopaminergic activation
and that's the exploration circuit that comes out of the hypothalamus.
Half the hypothalamus does goal specification.
Okay,
and the other half does exploration.
And so again,
if you're pursuing something that's an identifiable goal and you fail,
well then you're going to back off.
That's negative emotion.
Then you're going to start to explore and that's that dopaminergic circuit.
What's associated with dopaminergic activation,
exploration,
extroversion,
happiness,
play,
enthusiasm,
assertiveness and the positive element of novelty.
Okay,
so that makes sense.
Anybody have any questions?
I know that's a lot of information but I kind of designed this part of the
course so that at this point the levels of analysis would stack up so that you
could understand them simultaneously.
So the hypothalamus sets up your frames of motivation
running one of those to the co two.
It's positive conclusion.
That satisfying.
That's innate.
It's because it's conservatory reward.
You'll work for that.
Anything that indicates that that might happen,
that's incentive reward.
You can learn that.
But some of it's also a Nate,
which is where the behaviors didn't know that cause they thought of all the,
all the secondary stuff that condition stuff has learned.
Its not all learned.
Some of it's already prepared.
You see a snake,
that's a threat.
You don't have to learn that.
So fires sort of like that as well.
Um,
blood is like that.
Teeth are like that.
Staring eyes are like that.
Predatory postures are like that.
Um,
loud,
loud vocalizations,
especially if they're like low,
low in frequency,
they indicate a large animal.
All those things are things you don't have to learn to be afraid of because
they've been so consistently dangerous in the past that you've built up a
circuit that aren't responds automatically to the question.
It seems like there will,
at least in the example that he did,
but I'm kind of mutually eggs
or did you know what I mean?
Yeah,
it's complicated,
you know,
because they do play a bit of an inhibitory role,
but they're separate circuits,
you know,
so you can be very extroverted and very high in negative emotion.
Okay.
So,
and you can be very emotionally stable and very low in extroversion too.
but they are definitely separate things now.
It's hard,
you know,
you can flip from laughing to crying very rapidly,
you know?
So people are very much capable of experiencing mixed states of positive and
negative emotion.
Plus there are forms of manic depressive disorder where people are manic and
depressed at the same time,
which I would recommend the people I know that have had that,
they seem to think that is certainly not fun.
So
agitation,
tremendous agitation.
So you're probably sort of like that when you're deeply confused and you're
really bothered by it,
cause then the thread circuits are going,
but you're also sort of wandering around going,
oh,
what am I going to do?
That's all.
That's all like approach behavior approach.
Motivation isn't always positive a,
I mean most of the time it is,
but intensity measures and controllability matters too,
so,
okay.
Unconditioned punishments,
fundamentally they produce pain.
They also tend to Ha if you run a behavioral routine or a motivated framework
that results in punishment,
you're less likely to run it again in the future.
That's learning.
If you run a motivated frame and it works,
you're more likely to run it in the future.
That's learning too,
so I'm conditioned.
Punishments decreased the probability that you're going to run to given
motivational frame because it failed.
Right.
Do you,
you ran out and you got hurt.
It's like don't do that again.
That's part of the purpose of memory and the pain,
like emotions just to say it again.
Our pain,
frustration,
disappointment,
grief,
sadness is in there as well.
So those are paying like states of emotion,
conditioned punishments.
Those are things that indicate that a punishment is likely.
Some of them you can learn.
Some of them you don't have to because they're already built into the negative.
Emotions are dampened by Serotonin.
That's the fundamental brain system.
Fundamentally,
it's the serotonergic system is like a conductor of the orchestra.
It keeps everything in,
in balance and Gaba.
Gaba is a anxiety or lytic,
it makes people less anxious.
It's indogenous.
Your brain produces it.
If you take Valium or barbiturates,
they act on the Gaba system.
It's so does alcohol.
That's part of the reason why people like alcohol because it dampens anxiety.
Now for some people,
alcohol or also produces dopaminergic activation,
so they really like alcohol because it calms them down like they're not anxious
anymore and it also feels it produces incentive reward activation like cocaine.
So for some people,
alcohol is and absolutely deadly drug.
You can probably find out if you're susceptible to alcoholism quite
straightforwardly.
If you want to find out,
sit in a bar,
take your pulse
down,
five shots,
four shots.
If you're little,
you got to get your,
you got to get your blood alcohol level above legal intoxication or you won't be
able to tell and then take your pulse again 10 minutes later if your pulse has
gone up,
eight beats are more,
watch it because you're probably producing an opiate response to alcohol.
Secondary consequences of the opiate responses is a dopaminergic response.
Reasonable probability that you'll like alcohol enough to find it.
Difficult to stop drinking.
Once you start.
Some of you are probably like that,
right?
You have a few drinks.
It's like he ha,
that's how we do it in Alberta anyways,
so,
so part of that killing the incentive reward system and because it's an approach
system and it's being cued by the alcohol,
you just continue to hit it and the dopamine kicks only occur as your blood
alcohol level is rising.
So you have to keep nailing it,
nailing yourself with alcohol because otherwise your blood alcohol level won't
keep rising and you won't get that nice enthusiasm and assertiveness that goes
along with the pause.
Development of alcohol,
neuroticism.
So this is the neuroticism dimension.
Um,
there's this gender difference in neuroticism.
Women are about half a standard deviation,
higher negative emotion than men.
It's seems like a cross cultural universal,
the differences more enhanced.
And he galitary in states like Scandinavia,
which is exactly the opposite of what you'd presume,
right?
If you were,
say us,
uh,
a radical,
can't remember the name.
If you are someone who believes that everything occurs as a consequence of
socialization,
as you equalize the society,
the gender differences in personality become larger rather than smaller.
So,
which is,
you know,
not what anybody expected.
But that's what happened.
So boys and girls seem to have about the same level of negative emotion.
But as soon as puberty hits,
women become higher negative emotion than men on average.
There's still a lot of overlap between the genders and it never goes away again
across the life course.
Once it kicks in in puberty,
and the reasons for that,
women are smaller,
they're,
their upper bodies are weaker,
so they're more physical.
They're there at a physical disadvantage.
If they're in a dominance dispute,
they're sexually vulnerable,
plus they have to take care of infants.
So I think those four things are probably enough to tilt the nervous system of
women more towards negative negative emotion.
I've often thought maybe that women's Nate emotional systems,
the negative ones in particular are actually not tuned to the woman.
I think there are tuned to the woman incent combination.
So you know,
if you think about it from an,
if you think about it for bait,
it almost has to be that way because an infant has to be carried around for like
a year and a half.
And so at that point when you have an incident and maybe you're going to have 10
you know you guys won't,
but in the evolutionary paths,
that would have been the case.
You'd have an infant for a much,
much of your life and then you'd be a grandmother and have an incident.
It's like,
why wouldn't your nervous system be tuned at puberty for the two of you instead
of one of you?
So how could it be any other way?
Anyways,
so you've got your hypothalamus and then on top of that you've got some circuits
that deal with memory and emotion.
So I'm going to run you through the hippocampus and the Amygdala relatively
quickly.
So this is a theory that was basically put together by Sokolov who was a Russian
neuropsychologist back in 1962 but it's a variant of a theory that Norbert
Wiener developed back in the forties so here's the idea.
You wander through the world and you,
if you're in a place that you know,
okay,
your memory systems,
the HIPPA campus looks inside your memory systems to see what it is that you
want to have happen based on your understanding of the world.
Okay?
So you're in a motivated state,
but you have certain expectations that makes sense within that state.
So the hippocampus is watching what you think is going to happen.
But remember that's motivated.
It's not just the expectation.
And then the hippocampus is also looking at the world.
Now it's looking at it interpretation of the world because you can't help but
interpret the world.
But fundamentally the hippocampus is looking inside you and outside you.
And then it seeing if what's happening inside and what's happening outside are
the same,
which means you know what you're doing and you know where you are.
And if they're the same.
So if it detects a match,
then the hippocampus,
the inhibits the Amygdala and the hypothalamus,
roughly speaking.
Now what it actually seems to do,
there's a little circuit in your brain stem called the reticular activating
circuit.
And it's the thing that turns your brain on at night.
If you're sleeping and you hear a noise that you shouldn't hear,
it's like bang,
you're awake.
It's the reticular activating system.
Way Down in your brainstem,
puts your cortex into a high arousal state and Poof,
you're conscious.
Now the hippocampus tells the reticular activating system to basically remain
calm as well as,
as long as what you're expecting and desiring and what's happening are the same
thing.
So it's sort of like it's saying,
I know you could jump up and freak out and run about,
but you don't have to right now because everything's going according to plan.
But as soon as there's a deviation that's an normally say,
then the hippocampus says,
Whoa,
something's wrong here.
And uh,
it does inhibits their reticular activating system that turns on your emotions,
especially your negative emotion,
but it primes your positive emotion and it primes some of the hypothalamic
circuits to or disinhibiting them.
Because one way of solving the fact that something isn't going well is to switch
to something else.
So it's sort of like there's a bunch of circuits on underneath you,
but they're being held back like race horses in race horse and then something
that you don't expect happens.
And the gates come up a little bit because then you're prepared.
Now a lot of that's negative emotion.
Oh,
you don't know where you are.
But a lot of,
a lot of the rest of it is be prepared to do whatever the hell you might need to
do next.
And so what normally the hippocampus detects a,
normally that's something unexpected and then it does inhibits your lower
circuitry and it gets you ready to go.
Now the problem is,
okay,
how worried should you be when something that you don't expect happens?
Okay.
An answer to that is you don't know.
That's a big problem with life because now something went wrong.
Here's the possibilities.
You're not looking at the world,
right?
So it's actually a perceptual problem,
Like gray for example,
believes that you just see the world just like it is.
Cause he's sort of a behaviorist.
It's full of stimuli.
You don't have to interpret them.
That's wrong.
You have to interpret them.
So if something goes wrong,
it might be that you're looking at things wrong,
your perceptual systems are out.
It's unlikely.
But sometimes that's the case.
But forget that.
Let's say that you're looking at the world correctly and you know your
inferences about what went wrong,
what went wrong isn't the consequence of you misperceiving it's a consequence of
some stupid problem with your stupid plan.
The problem is you don't know where the error is located.
And that's why I think there's temperament.
Sometimes if something unexpected happens,
you should really freak out.
Other times you should ignore it,
but you can't tell which of those is true right away.
So what happens is there's a distribution with a little thing happens.
Some people really get upset about it and other people hardly care at all.
And sometimes the people who get really upset about it or write,
and sometimes the people who don't care at all are right.
And that's why there's variability in neuroticism,
okay?
Now what you do when you're exploring is you start to decompose your plan,
right?
If you're,
if you,
if you can manage it,
if you're not,
so like grip my anxiety that you're paralyzed.
Then you go into your plan and you think,
well,
am I a complete like loser or is it some micro thing that's gone wrong?
And then you can start to decompose it and reconstruct your plat.
Okay?
So,
yeah,
the other,
the other thing that this little diagram helps you understand.
It's like,
look,
what happens is when you're laying out a plan,
a motivated plan,
and a hole appears in it,
you have to figure out why you fell in the hole.
And then what you have to do is you have to take that motivated plan that's kind
of running on automatic and you have to remember what it's made out of.
And so what opens up underneath you when,
when you've made a mistake is the complexity,
the plant,
and then also potentially the complexity of the world on the off chance that
you've misperceived it,
right?
You're just,
someone might say,
you're not understanding me properly.
You know,
maybe there's something wrong with you that's interfering with the perception
and then you have to do this massive search to try to figure out where their
lives.
Now,
part of the reason I believe that people stick to their beliefs so hard is
because people don't like it when the hole appears in one of their big
abstractions,
right?
So they've got these high order representations of the world that are shorthand,
ways of representing something.
They're sort of like axioms of faith.
And if they,
if a hole appears in one of the axioms of faith,
then all this complexity comes rushing up and it's overwhelming.
And so people hate it when you undermine one of their high order abstractions.
And so I think I told you this before,
don't do that in relationships,
right?
It's best not to do it to yourself as well.
I'll start with this.
These are Medusa's.
And what happens when you see the Medusa?
Okay,
so what,
what might that mean?
You bet it's the,
it's a prey response.
And so that's a sort of,
that's the sort of thing that occurs when
you're moving towards your goal in your frame and the bottom drops out.
It's like,
oh,
what's there?
You don't know.
So what's the logical first response?
Well,
if you're high in neuroticism,
it's going to be this in a freeze.
And then,
and only then,
if nothing else terrible happens to you,
you'll start to relax a bit.
And then maybe you'll start to investigate the structure of your plan.
And maybe you'll start to investigate the structure of the world.
And then from a constructivist perspective,
say once you start to do that,
you gather information from the world,
and then you remake your plan and you remake your conception of the world,
and then you could move on.
So you do that under the guidance of the positive and the negative emotions.